- We've got Anthony Anderson with us.
(Kelly and audience
clapping and hollering)
Give it up.
So Anthony and I both grew up
in fairly strict households
I think.
So we wanted to see if
we got in trouble for any
of the same things.
I'm curious about this as well.
So it's time for a little
something called, and I
love you Jordan,
for coming up with this
title for this game.
Nuh uh, no I didn't!
(audience laughs)
(keyboard diddy)
- [Game Announcer] Nuh uh
No I didn't.
(diddy ends)
- Nuh uh, no I didn't.
I love it.
I laughed so hard when I
heard the title of that game.
I am gonna hit this button.
Thank you so much Justin.
We're very fancy
- Okay
- And so loaded.
- I got it. All right.
- I'll hit this button and something,
(Anthony dings button a few times)
something kids get
in trouble for will appear on the screen
and then Anthony and I will fess up
and say if we got in
trouble for it or not.
- Okay.
(Kelly hits button)
Let's see.
(game music)
(bell dings)
- Oh God. (Kelly laughs)
- Ah, oh.
- I mean 100%.
- All right.
- Talking too much in class.
Disturbing class.
I got kicked outta class.
Yeah
- I got kicked outta school for that.
- You did?
- I got kicked outta school.
Yeah. I got su suspended.
- I didn't, I didn't get that.
And I think the only reason maybe how
I didn't get that
is cuz I was a little bit smarter
than my other friend who used
to get in trouble with me.
- [Anthony} Okay.
- And she'd get caught more than me.
- [Anthony] All right.
Yeah, no.
- So I was that jerk friend.
- [Anthony] No, I was, I was the,
I was the student who did that so often
that they were like
you know detention's
not good enough for you.
We got, we got to suspend you.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
I always had detention.
- Yeah. I was suspended.
- Did you, were you allowed
to get whooped in school?
The principal whooped me.
- Yes.
We look, I'm 52, so I grew up in an era
- [Kelly] I'm 40.
- where they beat you
with a wooden paddle.
- [Kelly] Yeah, paddle.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, which was a form of child abuse.
I don't understand how the
- [Kelly] Totally.
- School system allowed that to happen
(audience laughs)
to babies.
- [Kelly] Now I will say
I was very afraid of that paddle.
So once it hit, I think
it only happened twice,
And then you learned and look
(Anthony laughs)
I'm a really nice individual now.
- Look at, look at how we turned out.
- I turned out great. I'm
in therapy and everything!
- Yes, (Anthony and Kelly
laugh, audience claps)
- But I will say I was,
I was, I was a good
amount of healthy fear.
- All right, come on,
let's see if we can
get the Skinny Dipping.
(Kelly laughs and pushes button)
(gaming music playing)
Skinny Dipping! Come, on Skinny Dipping!
(Kelly laughs, bell dings)
- [Kelly] Oh man. Caught lying to parents.
- My mama taught me how to lie.
- Oh!
- So.
- There's another parent parental book.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I got caught lying
to my parents cause my
mama taught me how to lie.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Mm hmm. Yep.
- I'm trying to I don't-
- My mama taught me how to steal and lie.
- Okay.
- And then when I got caught stealing,
she would be like,
Well, I didn't teach
you how to get caught.
- [Kelly] She didn't lie about it.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- I didn't teach you how to get caught.
That was her excuse.
I didn't teach you how to get caught.
I taught you how to steal and lie.
- My mom did this thing,
like if I was lying
she wouldn't say a word.
And it was like silence
- Mm hmm.
- Because I would torture myself.
I'd tell on myself.
- [Anthony] Oh, okay.
- Do you tell on yourself?
- No, I don't snitch on myself.
- Oh. I snitch on myself.
- Snitches get stitches. Nuh uh.
- I know, but I always
tell my friends, I'm like
don't tell anybody I did this.
And then I walk in the door.
I'm like, okay.
So whenever I was out
there, I totally did.
And I just out myself.
- Okay.
- I know.
- Well, I know not to
commit a crime with you.
(Kelly laughs)
- Don't!
- Hit the button. Let's go Kelly Clarkson.
- Don't (Kelly laughs)
- Skinny Dipping in the pool!
- Last one.
- [Anthony] Skinny-Mm hmm.
(Kelly laughs)
- Buying jewelry with parents money.
Oh, my parents didn't have money.
- I did that.
Damn, I did all this stuff.
- Wait, you what?
- So I, my mother put me in piano lessons
but we didn't have a piano.
So I took my mother's credit card
and I bought a baby grand piano.
(Kelly gasps and audience laughs)
But I also saw an advertisement
for a fake gold ring with
a cubic zirconia in it.
And I was like, well if I buy this piano
I'm gonna get in trouble.
But if I buy my daddy this gold ring
he not going to beat me.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
So let me buy the piano and the gold ring.
- The justification.
Yeah. A baby grand is a lot of money.
- Baby grand piano.
Yeah. And they delivered it.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my
God
- And they delivered the ring
and my mama beat me and
send the piano back.
(Kelly laughs)
But my daddy kept his fake gold ring.
(audience laughs)
- So you were kind of right.
- Yeah, yeah right,
He thought about it.
He said, oh, you thought about me, son.
That's good.
(Kelly giggles)
- I only, I never really
buy jewelry, but I did.
I just thought of it.
I did take money from
my mom's purse one time.
We lived in an apartment complex and I,
I took like a 20 because the
ice cream truck had come in
and everybody it was a hot day.
And I thought, wouldn't it be nice
if I like got everyone some ice cream?
So I went in my mom's purse,
the one and only time
(Kelly laughs)
that happened and I got $20 out
and I bought everyone ice cream.
So I, I was kind of Robin
Hood, you know, it was nice.
I was doing things for the people.
- Mm hmm.
- But no, I got in a lot of trouble.
- [Anthony] Of Course you did.
- Yeah. She was like, I
mean, she lost her mind.
- You took your mama's money for the week!
- I know, I know.
We were really poor.
I'm, I think I've
I've made up for it a little bit, mom.
Um uh, that's
(Anthony laughs)
- [Kelly] Cause I. I do know it was wrong.
(audience laughs)
I'm trying to make up for it.
The trip Italy,
- Yeah.
- Like I'm just saying.
I'm trying to make up for it anyway.
And that is nu-uh, no, I didn't.
(audience clapping)
Go online for more information
on how you can get real
about diabetes ya'll.